let me see your hands come on put them
to drop the knife nope drop the knife
intense moments show what led up to a
deadly officer-involved shooting when a
suspect refused to drop his knife
the incident happened on March 4th in
Frederick Maryland about an hour west of
Baltimore officers there were searching
for 44 year old Joseph Sherrell who had
a warrant out for violating probation
it's Frederick police
[Applause]
the Maryland Office of the Attorney
General released this body camera video
following the shooting the video opens
with officers speaking to shirelle's
ex-wife she says he's not inside her
home
hello what's going on what's that in
front of the door
because my ex-husband
ex parte I guess so who's that Joseph
shirelle is he here no I always keep
that in front of the door you're over
here the other night was he here the
other night no he was not officers tell
the woman they received a tip from
Neighbors that shirelle is inside her
home well I've been somebody called and
said he's here well he's not here
and I'm sure it is his baby's mother
because I had a protective order and I
had custom the other kid I'm so sick of
her I'm so sick and tired of all of this
bull crap shirelle's ex-wife says she's
recently been visited by other officers
also looking for him he was not he's not
here he was here I put him out I keep
this in front of the door so that I
don't have this problem of people coming
here in the middle of the night in the
middle of the day and I I had to get
myself he's not here then we'll be gone
well I just don't think that it's right
that you're you're in like whoever's
calling you tell them to come here he's
not here the woman continues to maintain
her ex-husband is not inside her home
saying he's recently been seen at Area
Hotels well somebody called us we didn't
just show up here he's not here I'm I'm
sick as a dog I've been sick for three
weeks over this whole effing thing he's
out running around the subject the last
I knew he was at the Hampton Inn up on
opossum Turnpike they were staying at
the motel six I'm telling you I am so
sick of all the bullcrap with him like
I'm not having him here officers
continue to press the woman asking
whether they can come inside so we can't
come in and make sure he's not here no
because I'm I thought first of all I
don't have any pants on I do have pants
on I do not have pants when I just put
my pants okay you have jeans on it okay
I am in bed I'm sick as a dog I'm
sleeping his baby's mom has the kids he
is not here you can go to those hotels
and look for him those are the two last
places that I heard that he was staying
with her eventually officers say they
believe shirelle is inside the home as
his ex-wife maintains he's not there why
do you need to come in for there's no
protection to make sure he's not here
because he's not supposed to be here
what do you mean here there is no
protective order is dropped it was
dropped yes okay so then we should be
able to come in and take a look and make
sure I don't know because we have a
summons for him
you're the way a summons just a piece of
paper Captain I gave that to him that
came in my mail the other day okay well
we have to hand deliver it to him well I
don't know what to tell you go to the
Hampton Inn
I think he's here I'm telling you he's
not here so then why don't we come in
and take a look I'll tell it because I'm
not letting you you I don't trust you
guys it's then the police say the woman
could be arrested if she's lying to them
well if I find out he's here okay and
you're lying to me okay okay I'm gonna
arrest you okay that's fine he's not
here okay so just so as long as you're
okay with being arrested
after that she allows officers inside
what's your name
officers can be heard calling out for
shirelle who does not answer Joseph if
you're here let us know now
I'm telling you
I'm moving
while searching through one of the rooms
officers come face to face with shirelle
shut up
let me see your hands come on
put them in the drop the knife nope drop
the knife drop the knife
body camera video shows officers backing
out of the room working to bring
shirelle's ex-wife out of the situation
approaches officers saying quote I'm not
going to jail after that officers opened
fire inside the home
hey drop the knife
Drive the knife
he's right there hey hey hey
another officer's body camera video
shows the shooting from a different
angle
are you watching him yes I go he's right
there hey
two officers fired shots at shirelle who
was later pronounced dead on the scene
right now an investigation into the
deadly shooting is still underway
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie